whenever I'm going through a rough time
I remind myself that you cannot wish for
both strong character and an easy life
because the price of one is the other if
you're going through hard times then it
means that you're paying the price to
have the character you ultimately want
and if you have an easier life then
oftentimes we sacrifice the hard-built
character and since most of us probably
would identify as having a harder life
or the things that we're willing to
endure then I think it's just simply
asking ourselves did we ultimately want
to be the types of people who could
endure this thing and if so then we are
just walking the journey that will give
us the evidence that we are who we say
we are